écoutez l'envoyé spécial de france 24 à
dnipro dans le centre du pays john allan
walsh
en matière de communication de guerre il
faut évidemment toujours être très
prudent le gouverneur de la région de
lougansk que les officiers de la région
disent tous qu'ils ont repris 50% de la
ville de c02 n'y est que aujourd'hui
c'est impossible
complètement impossible à vérifier de
manière indépendante
indépendante il y a des nouvelles qui
arrivent régulièrement de la part d'un
journaliste activiste qui est avec les
forces ukrainienne depuis le début de
l'invasion us il est aujourd'hui à
l'intérieur de ces verrous d'agnès il
envoie régulièrement ses vidéos ses
photos des combats à l'intérieur de la
ville et pour lui 50% c'est c'est très
exagéré voilà donc en tout cas en tout
cas les ukrainiens de 10,10 reprendre le
dessus mais pour l'instant les combats
font toujours rage et encore une fois
impossible d'avoir des idées très
claires sur sur ce qui se passe là bas
pour ce qui est du reste du dombass nous
étions hier dans la région de deux
thoniers est prêt de près de davie fla
et or est ce qu est la situation est
très différente là bas et les positions
de l'armée régulière tiennent bon à la
fois depuis le début de l'invasion russe
mais même depuis depuis des années
presque depuis
2014 et pour l'instant les positions sur
sur cette ligne de démarcation avec les
positions séparatistes et bien elles
n'ont absolument pas bouger